[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing a few new
harry potter plot holes but for this
video rather than me theorizing these
plot holes myself i'm going to be
covering my favorite ones that you harry
potter theory fans have come up with as
you may know i've previously released a
video on the topic of 10 huge harry
potter plot holes
ranked at the end of the video i
requested as i do in all my videos for
you to share your thoughts in the
comments below
some of you made excellent points on the
potholes i'd covered offering additional
details on a few and even possible
explanations for others
many of you however shared your own plot
hole theories and merlin's bid might i
just say there were far too many great
ideas put forth for them to go
unacknowledged so in this video i've
compiled my favorite top 10 of your plot
hole theories without further ado let's
let the magic unravel
number one the pensive by colton smith
at the end of the fourth book why didn't
harry put his memory of voldemort's
return in the pensive then show it to
fudge and other ministry people
that would have solved almost all the
problems of the fifth book
with 1800 thumbs up this plot hole
theory got a lot of support from many
other fans and for good reason i mean
why didn't harry do this he could have
easily proven his innocence to fudge
while simultaneously proving that
voldemort was back
a few of you responded to this comment
with a possible answer to the plot hole
that is since memories can be altered
fudge may have accused harry of simply
changing the memory to match with his
story however this is quite a difficult
bit of magic
and as we know harry wasn't actually the
strongest when it came to these types of
spells at least not at this stage in the
series
remember at this point he hadn't even
begun his occlumency lessons with
professor snape in which he does not
immediately excel
a few other fans mentioned that perhaps
fudge may have then accused dumbledore
of altering harry's memory since fudge
had already concluded that harry and
dumbledore were colluding while that may
be true i still think this is an
excellent plot hole theory that's worthy
of some debate
2. petunia's magical knowledge by some
other dude
it states early in book 2 that all of
the dursleys didn't know harry wasn't
allowed to use magic outside of school
because he was underage at least until
the letter started coming in that told
them
how did petunia not know that underage
wizards and witches weren't allowed to
use magic outside of school when she
grew up around lily i love this plot
hole theory and to be completely honest
it's not one i'd ever thought about but
of course petunia should have known this
a few other fans responded to this
comment with the idea that perhaps
petunia had such a denial complex about
lily's magic that she blocked out
everything to do with the wizarding
world
but you'd think that when it was right
under her nose taking place in her very
own home something would have resonated
and brought back these suppressed
memories from her childhood in relation
to lily i mean as a child petunia went
so far as to send a letter to dumbledore
requesting that she'd be admitted to the
magical school despite her lack of being
well a witch
that's to say that she was so aware of
how the magical school of witchcraft and
wizardry worked that she knew how to
contact the headmaster
three the chamber of secrets by petros
cosmos a part i always considered a
major plot hole is that how he
discovered the entrance of the chamber
of secrets but dumbledore couldn't
harry found out that myrtle was the girl
that died 50 years ago and asked her how
did you die
but dumbledore was there 50 years ago
and he knew that myrtle was the girl who
died so why when the chamber was opened
again didn't he immediately go to myrtle
and ask her everything about her death
it seems pretty strange that a wizard
like dumbledore couldn't figure this out
of course he wouldn't be able to open
the chamber but still he would know
where the entrance was
this is another great plot hole in my
opinion shouldn't dumbledore have known
to ask myrtle there's always a theory
that he did know or knew he could ask
myrtle but was grooming harry to one day
go up against voldemort
i personally would hate to think that
this was true but then again it would
make sense because the very idea that
dumbledore wouldn't have thought to
inquire to myrtle just doesn't match up
4. marauders map mistake by joe jackson
i noted another plot hole in the third
book when lupin finds sirius harry ron
and hermione in the shrieking shack he
claims that he knew they were there
because he saw them on the marauders map
surely if this was the case he would
have seen two versions of harry and
hermione as they had gone back in time
and were only 30 40 feet behind them
surely lupin would have been rather
confused
this theory brings up an excellent point
the only reasoning i can think of that
would explain it is that the marauders
map does not seem to be a terribly
honest magical item
for example apparently anime guy could
only be seen on the map in their animal
form
if the viewer knew that that which or
wizard was an anime guy
in other words it would lie to the
viewer this explains why only lupin was
able to see peter pettigrew on the map
when he was in the form of ron's pet
scabbers so perhaps future selves were
also not shown on the map
unless the viewer knew to look for them
there
number five the problems with sirius by
srinidy prakash
sirius alone creates a bunch of problems
one beginning a philosopher's stone
dumbledore doesn't ask any questions
when hagrid says he borrowed syriza's
bike despite sirius being the one
presumed to have betrayed the potters
two owls always found serious when he
was on the run so why couldn't the
ministry
three
why did no castle portraits see sirius
breaking in tell the staff about how he
got in and where he went i really have
nothing to say about these plot holes
other than i think they're bloody
brilliant and incredibly spot on
6. the hogwarts express by darren thorpe
also does the hogwarts express really
only run from king's cross to hogsmeade
non-stop if we take neville for instance
who is clearly from yorkshire in the
films at least that's roughly halfway
between london and scotland
why does he have to go to london to get
a train back up past yorkshire and on to
hogwarts and what about cho chang and
oliver wood do they really have to go
from scotland to london back to scotland
again we definitely see cho do this in
the films why is everything so london
centric
this is a fantastic logistical plot hole
do the students who come from northern
uk all have to travel down to london to
then travel back up north to hogwarts
castle in scotland this seems completely
illogical
especially for a world filled with magic
7. hagrid's werewolf cubs by eden b
my favorite plot hole is in i think the
second book where someone says that
hagrid when he was a student raised
werewolf cubs under his bed so he
literally had human babies living under
his bed for all but one night a month
where they transformed lol wtf rolling
this is just hilarious i view it less as
a plot hole and more of just a giant
oversight but no matter how you view it
it is certainly a mistake
clearly the intention here was for
hagrid to have kept magical creatures
under his bed not human babies
8. charlie's wand by robin j 1939
the plot hole i always remember is that
ron's wand was actually charlie's former
wand ones are not items for people to
pass down like how a younger sibling may
wear their older siblings hand-me-downs
charlie should still need his one for
various things so giving it away just
makes life harder for him
this is such an interesting plot hole to
me because of course i always assumed
ron got charlie's old one since the
weasley family didn't have all that much
money to go around
but if ron got charlie's wand charlie
would have needed a new wand and as
robin j 1939 says ones are not meant to
be passed down in fact they are known to
rebel and not work properly for witches
or wizards with whom it did not
originally match with so either charlie
was oneless which we know wasn't the
case or a new wand was purchased for him
why not keep the wand meant for him and
get wrong his own it's not like it would
have been worn out like a pair of old
shoes very odd indeed
9. snape's potions textbook by montecito
why did snape donate his old potions
book to the school for it to be loaned
out he doesn't seem the generous type
especially with zone notes all
throughout it
this plot hole theory made me laugh
no severus snape does not seem like the
generous type does he some responses to
this theory however mentioned that
perhaps he had left it on purpose to
help harry progress through the class
and ultimately improve his magical
abilities as he was getting nearer and
nearer to facing voldemort after all at
one point in the half-blood prince he
recognizes that harry is using the
textbook that once belonged to him and
not only does he not take it away but he
also doesn't punish harry for cheating
either
10. voldemort's visit to the ministry by
sav g one thing that always gets me is
in the fifth book voldemort spends the
whole year luring harry to the
department of mysteries to get the
prophecy because he doesn't want to risk
coming to the ministry himself for fear
of exposure but yet turns up anyway when
harry is there and ends up revealing
himself
this plot hole is so spot-on
i really don't think there's any
explanation that could solve this one at
least in my opinion
and with that we've wrapped up my
favorite top 10 fan plot holes thank you
for sharing it was great fun to read
through all of your comments and get
different perspectives from you all i
hope to hear more objections
explanations and theories in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel
until next time
what exactly is the function of a rubber
duck
[Music]
you